seven months with the Apple airpod Pro
twos two no wait oh my God it's in the
third
second gen yes it is okay I can't even
tell you how excited I was when these
were first announced and I test them out
at Apple because they now come with the
extra small ear tips and that has
completely redesigned the way that these
are able to fit in some people's ears
mine included previously I had not been
able to wear any of these with the soft
ear tips so I have been using the old
basically like the first generation
airpods which clearly don't have as good
of sound quality and the Bluetooth
connectivity isn't as fast I could not
believe my ears when I first got my ears
on these put these in my ears I've been
loving them I have two pairs give me two
per I need two perm edit that out that's
dumb so I got two of them which I'm
gonna show you why because one of them
has my little emoji on it and I think
that was one of the coolest things is
being able to customize your air pods
with your memoji the coolest thing
though is it actually will show you the
memoji on the animation I'm sure some of
you have seen this if you do have one
but if you haven't like this is such a
cool and cute little addition ah it's so
great another thing that I liked about
these is you can use your Apple watch
charger to charge them and that has been
so crucial for me with traveling because
I don't have to bring any extra Chargers
I use the magsafe duo charger so with
that I can actually charge both of these
at the same time you're probably like
just seeing why do you have two of them
well because I lost one so then I got
another one but then I found the other
one so now I have two and I tend to
usually travel with both because I at
times one of them does end up getting
misplaced but usually it comes back they
added this little Loop for a lanyard so
one of mine has this nice little Belkin
lanyard on it which is I was gonna say
it's super cute but like it's super
basic it's just a little string
um yeah I don't that's not cute it's
functional these have also held up
pretty well you may have seen the tragic
almost death of the memoji ones I put
them through a full freaking cycle in my
laundry it was the saddest thing ever I
went and started putting my clothes in
the dryer and then I saw them so what I
did is I immediately took them out like
it felt waterlogged like I could feel it
I covered them in those little silica
gel packets and I was like okay this is
definitely gonna air it out so I put
that on top of like this air purifier so
it was just like this consistent stream
of air and I came back like a week later
from traveling and guess what that
little light turned on I still use them
all the time and have had no loss in
audio no loss in battery basically they
are like brand new just very very clear
as a runner these have been amazing
there have been a few times where
they've fallen out I still have strange
ears I just can't help it but very very
rarely do they ever actually fall out
because before they were unwearable for
me I would wear them but like if I I
wouldn't be able to move or I couldn't
smile I couldn't talk I could just like
not move and I would use them on
Converse calls because they sounded so
good but now like I don't have to worry
about that like I can just go and exist
and live my life with my airpods in my
ear which are usually a sign that says
don't talk to me but yet some people
they don't really get the memo look at
them look at this look at me I I am an
airpods Pro
user now I just want to give you guys an
update about how I've been liking some
of my tech recently I feel like a lot of
times when we make review videos we
never actually go back and talk about
how we're liking it afterwards so for me
the airpods Pro 2 have definitely passed
the long-term test these are something
that I use pretty much every single day
I do even edit with them even though
there is a slight Bluetooth lag but I
feel like I've kind of been able to
adjust my editing to know precisely how
much lag there is and I'll end up making
it work leave me some comments below and
let me know what headphones you guys use
thanks for watching I'll see you guys in
later